[Music]
this great big story is made possible by
Lexus experience amazing to play the
instrument that is utilizing our gentle
earth it's like you are becoming one
with the instrument in a very true way
you just sit and go yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're looking at the grates to leg pipe
organ of the Luray Caverns in Luray
Virginia when I press a key it sends an
electrical pulse up to a rubber tipped
mallet which strikes the stalactite
causing it to vibrate and producing a
incredibly beautiful musical tone the
area that the strikers cover is roughly
three and a half acres which then makes
it literally the world's largest musical
instrument it is a very gentle sound of
very peaceful there's only one like it
in the world and it's something
incredibly different and wonderfully
beautiful
[Music]
there's the rulers the reverb tank the
e-book
[Music]
a normal instrument you're playing it
and you're expecting it to have a sound
that is pleasing but with an instrument
like this the goal is to just produce
sounds that in this case so disturbing
[Music]
the apprehension engine was an
instrument that creates a variety of
really creepy and someone say horrifying
sounds
my name is Marc Corvin I'm a film music
composer and lately I've been focusing
on horror movie scores two of my biggest
hits as far as horror films are
concerned was from the late 90s a film
called cube and most recently the witch
I originally commissioned the
apprehension engine because I was tired
and the same digital samples which which
resulted in a lot of sameness of a lot
of horror musics so I was looking for
something more experimental more
acoustic that would give me a little bit
more of an original sound that's where I
contacted my friend Tony Duggan Smith
[Music]
so Mart called me asking me to create a
crazy instrument for horror films
because I'd never done anything like
that before
it may be empty out my pockets and all
my drawers of any knickknacks and bits
and bobs I could possibly spend together
to make it happen for him and this is
what Canada
[Music]
you're doing those things that stir
primal motions and feelings and there
actually is a skill set that you have to
acquire in order to to get the most out
of it
it expresses what really can't be
expressed any other way it's not music
in the traditional sense at all but let
me put it this way the apprehension
engine definitely evokes an emotion so I
would call it easy
[Music]
very often people think it's gonna be
funny and then they realize it's not
really we really do music it's not
impossible to make music with vegetables
[Music]
my name is Susanna got Naya and then I'm
a member of the vegetable orchestra the
orchestra exists since 18 years now if
there's instrument roasted tomato
because you can do sound with tomatoes
but it will be messy for sure we go
shopping on the market first we choose
all the vegetables there we have three
kinds of instruments one is the ready
mate you can just buy it at the market
and play it it's like the pepper it's
cold it's ready already
and then there are the simple
instruments like with one cut or some
cuts to get it like that then with the
more complex instruments we have some
that work like normal instruments you
know the pumpkin is the bass drum and
the sound of the pumpkin is really
important after shopping we go to the
venue and start to build instruments all
in all it takes 2 to 3 hours to build
all the instruments for everybody and
then we start with the soundcheck and
since we have new instruments each time
we have to have a very long soundcheck
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a lot of different musical
influences in the orchestra since there
really many people everybody's
interested in different things we make
soup during the building process of the
vegetable instruments with the remaining
vegetables when we serve it to the
audience after the concert and it's also
after hearing and seeing us and smelling
the vegetables which will be intense in
there because it's so small this theater
and then you can also eat it you never
get it out of your head
any more if you're in the orchestra to
look vegetables in another way
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm the first woman to graduate with a
doctorate from Juilliard and now I play
the toy piano life works in mysterious
ways
I have transformed the toy piano into a
rail instrument to play at the toy plane
oh well you have to practice on it every
bit as hard as you would on a normal
piano in fact I think you have to work
even harder because the action is so
primitive you can make it sound
beautiful you can make it sound
convincing it's a bit like going down
the rabbit hole and taking your audience
with you way back down this Avenue to
your childhood days what a skeptical
person comes to a toy piano concert that
I give I'm able to turn him around it's
a whole extended family now of people
into toy pianos it's a fearless little
band and we're willing to stick their
necks out for toys
[Music]